so today we want to answer the question
in our brown eggs better or healthier
than white eggs the answer is no there's
no difference the reason why an egg is a
certain color whether it's blue or
whatever is because of the type of
chicken and the reason why it's a little
more expensive than have brown eggs is
simply because that chicken is a little
bit bigger and they have to feed the
chicken more so the question is what do
you base the health of that egg on is it
this if it's a hundred percent natural
or how about cage free or free-range
they're able to leave the cage and go
within the barn right or what about
pasture-raised
well that's definitely one this is what
you want to consume right here
pasture-raised eggs not pasteurized okay
because that destroys all the nutrition
what about vegetarians and fed well all
that means is you're giving them grains
which we already know anyway but this
right here is GMO unless it says organic
it's so funny that when you see
vegetarian fed like what else are they
going to feed the chickens right like
other than like some meat or something
that doesn't make sense but you
definitely want organic and you want
pasture-raised these two right here and
ideally buying eggs from a local farmer
or the farmers market would be the best
thing to do and that's what I do
the eggs just taste better and instead
of using insecticides they might use
like clove and herbs and garlic which
definitely improves the taste of the egg
as well now that egg rating system that
you might have seen where it's rated a
or double-a really just tells you if the
egg is free of blemishes or if it's all
the same size and the shell is clean I
mean you can pretty much ignore this
right here for health when you consume
pasture-raised organic eggs you're going
to notice that the yolk is dark orange
okay versus pale yellow and that is
simply because of the carotenoids the
phytonutrients in that egg it's loaded
with lutein and zeaxanthin Acula
degeneration and cataracts and it also
helps your brain as well now if the yolk
breaks easily or you actually open the
egg and it's already broken
it just means that that egg is older
okay but the majority of nutrients are
in the yolk loaded with choline which is
really good to prevent a fatty liver
good for neurotransmitters good for your
brain it's loaded with selenium which is
really important in detoxification
biotin helping your nails your hair be
strong it provides a really good source
of vitamin A de k2 these are the fat
soluble vitamins this is involved in
vision bone health heart health calcium
metabolism preventing arthritis
stiffness things like that has b12 in it
phosphorus which by the way we need a
lot of this nutrient right here and
omega-3 fatty acid now i consume four
eggs every single day and i love eggs
and no eggs don't increase your
cholesterol I'll put a link down below
for those of you that still have that
idea because it's not true so a real
quick story one time I was doing a
seminar for Exxon the corporation and I
did a lot of seminars around town and
governmental agencies but I did a
seminar to Exxon on some health topic it
was a series of I think it was a series
of six seminars and so I know this after
I did the seminar they really liked it
but they didn't invite me back okay and
I was curious about this so I called
them I says why don't you want me to
come back to finish up the series of
seminars that I do and the lady says
well we can't have you back because
you're recommending they and also you're
telling people that you're consuming 45
eggs a day and I said no it wasn't 45
eggs a day I said four to five eggs
today so apparently I was talking too
fast and didn't clarify that point so
they did invite me back for the rest of
the series all right guys thanks for
watching
so I want to thank you for being here
and watching my videos if you haven't
already subscribed go ahead and do so so
you can stay informed of future videos